[Music]
[Applause]
give it up welcome
welcome welcome everybody to fat man
beyond i'm kevin smith
i am mark bernard
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you uh for the second week uh
we're
live here at smod castle in new jersey
leonardo new jersey
mere steps away from quick stop mark of
course
uh at the tva as we could see
how are things there after last week's
episode topsy turvy does anyone
recognize you
uh well you know it turns out they
needed another black dude in charge so
here i am
[Laughter]
how many variants are there of you so
many
but they're all doing the exact same
thing right now
he's like wait till you meet the other
one he's a way better writer
good to see you sarah how has your week
been uh the week has been good my friend
the week has been good you know aside
from
the standard slow decline of western
civilization
it's been fine truly truly uh before we
dive deep into anything uh
is anyone paying for the show this week
or are we just free to do whatever we
please
bamf uh yeah we had a couple we got a
couple sponsors
joined us for the first time
uh i'm waving to the people at smod
castle and nobody can see me there
i see you that's what they can't see me
he doesn't pop up on the screen
all they see is mark bernard so the kids
here it's modcast
have to take my word for it the bamf man
is there but they're hearing them and i
promise you he's there
anyway back to you jc yeah we're gonna
kick off the night with a uh our
favorite sponsor blue chew
and then we'll hit up manscaped a little
bit later
well kids i can feel an erection growing
right now
because tonight's sponsor of fat man
beyond is good folks at blue chew give
it up for the blue chew kids
as you can see i have no copy in front
of me so i'm gonna have to turn to my
good friend mark bernardin who has
all of the copies in front of them and
say mark where can we send them
while we're doing the ad bluechew.com i
assume correct
indeed yes bluechew.com um
then promo code is fat man get your
first month free but i want to read you
this bit
because the good folks at blue chews
copy writing department
is firing on all cylinders so let me let
me just give you their top line
smells like we got some good dick jokes
coming oh it's so good
it's like you can tell your mom because
they're not dirty right
they're close they're close okay so
it's summer camping season let's talk
about
pitching tents that's right this episode
is sponsored by bluetooth
i've gotten away with worse than that
for [ __ ] fifa films that's really
good
that's what i'm saying
not so bad guys confidence can take you
far in life it can also help in the
bedroom
especially when it comes time to step up
to the plate that's where bleach comes
in
uh that was a couple of mixed metaphors
but whatever
it really was that was like stepping up
to the oh you need a bat
and i guess a dick could be a bat
sure and there are like balls but you're
not hitting them
i would have went with like it's time to
grill that wiener or something like that
but
still be it uh blue chew is a unique
unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in chewable tablets
and at a fraction of the cost you can
take them anytime
day or night so you can plan ahead or be
ready
whenever the opportunity arises
is it weird that i want one right now it
sounds delicious
unlike most food i eat it won't just
make me fat it'll give me an erection
it will it will make a part of you very
fat
that's true
the best part it's all done online so no
visits to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations
no waiting in line at the pharmacy and
the tablets are made in the usa
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door in a discreet package
so it's [ __ ] patriotic to buy blue
chew it really is
you know if you need to stand and salute
the flag
where can they go to get this mark uh
where can you go
well you can go to bluetooth.com and if
you we got a special deal for fat man
and beyond listeners
try bluetooth for free when you use our
promo code fatman at checkout
just pay five dollars shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code fatman to
receive your first month free
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information
and we thank bluechu for sponsoring the
podcast
you were really busy reading the copy
so you missed like the high drama
of [ __ ] the luke skywalker of bugs
making an end run in my [ __ ] this
[ __ ] bug went
right to my eye as if like [ __ ] it
that's not even the first one today i
was at the house with my wife
and a bug [ __ ] went right to my i was
i was smoking a joint it went right to
my mouth i'm like what are you dumb or
something like
something wrong with the bugs out here
in any event that one was trying to grab
some screen time
good folks at blue chew um apparently
that bug got a hold of some
indeed he was feeling every last bit of
his life
uh we thank the good folks at bluetooth
for being uh sponsors of fat man beyond
give it up for the good folks at blue
he's here man
[Laughter]
he's getting ready for his second run
he is turning around turn that way
you see him this year oh damn
he's committed pac committed either that
he's like i've always wanted to be in
show business
oh buddy here's your microphone here's
your chance
no he's out for blood he's looking for
me or my wallet you son of a [ __ ]
regardless we got a third um hey man
guess what good things come to those who
wait mark remember the pandemic
the one the the old one not the one
that's about to happen apparently
we're all still in yeah we would sit
around we'd do fat man be uh beyond from
home and and uh
we popularized the mistaken catch phrase
jeff's kiss um remember that oh
those are the days yes i remember we
were like we should do a [ __ ] t-shirt
and that was like eight months ago
t-shirts were done mark wow
oh look at that the
jeff's kiss t-shirt as drawn by the
great dark nate gonzalez is available
right now i'm sure
jc will put the link up there and a
photo uh of the shirt
maybe i don't know did you get a picture
of the shirt yeah oh look at that [ __ ]
it's it looks slow in the dark i don't
know if it does
turn off the lights man here's where you
got to help me out now
[ __ ] people have been bugging me
about this shirt since i've
said oh it's coming and then it didn't
come and [ __ ]
so now you know uh
um i was uh jordan is the one that kind
of makes everything happen in our
business as you know
and so i've been like bugging her for
months going like you gotta [ __ ] make
this shirt i keep telling the people the
shirts coming and stuff
so i i was like you you know i threw my
head over the wall i was like
you need to order a thousand of these
shirts and she's like what are you nuts
and i was like we got a lot of people
watching that show
and everybody uses that catchphrase
and she's like everybody i was like at
least i don't know 500 or something so i
said get a thousand shirts and let's see
if we can
move them and stuff so don't please
don't make me look like a [ __ ]
in front of you know my boss slash
jason's wife like you know
she she was doubting my my high order
number but i was like i'm telling you
i i think we'll hit it i think we'll
sell it so go to uh
janesonbob.com and the link somewhere in
there or
was it bitly does that bug get back in
um jeff slash jeff's kiss order that
shirt
and and make me write ladies and
gentlemen please love of god
i gotta say [ __ ] face and it's a
wicked wicked [ __ ] shirt
uh mark you'll be getting yours very
soon outstanding
i expected a a small a girls small
shall we uh dive into the loki of it all
i think we should dive into the loki at
all let's do it kids uh
if you're watching at home or if you're
watching right here in the room
and you're like i haven't [ __ ] seen
the season finale you are [ __ ]
because we're gonna talk the [ __ ] about
the season finale right now spoilers
abound ladies and gentlemen so cover
yours
uh for the next i don't know 20 minutes
if you haven't seen it yet
um or come back and see us after you've
watched it um
one of my favorite visuals i've ever
seen
in a marvel movie happened in the season
finale of loki
very simple imagery that brought with it
so much promise so much hope and showed
us the future
uh in the third act as the timelines
branching like crazy and you see
all those [ __ ] tendrils going off of
the sacred timeline
it just filled me with [ __ ] glee
because i'm like that's the next
five ten years of our lives same way
that like the infinity
gauntlet and the gems the stones took up
like the giant the lion's share of all
the marvel movies up until end game and
stuff
we are now going to be dealing with
multiverse [ __ ]
for the next five to 10 [ __ ] years
and watching those
tendrils like spiraling off going that
is
spider-man you know no way home that is
doctor strange
multiverse of madness that is ant-man
quantum mania and stuff like that
ant-man and the wasp quantum meaning
just made me so [ __ ] happy it was so
dire for everyone in the show i felt bad
for all those [ __ ] but for me i was
like
i was like oh this is gonna [ __ ] rock
like
you know and i was just telling you
jennifer was like oh my god that's
so bad for the timeline and [ __ ] i was
like [ __ ] the timeline that's good for
us
[ __ ] like movies now and what made me
really happy was like
at this point based on that visual
isn't everything canon like is it
isn't that aren't the cartoons canon
isn't like agents of shield
cannon at this point if there's that
many different multiverses at this point
i feel like
wow even like even though the week
before they were like agent coulson's
dead
i felt like with that episode they're
like and now agent coulson
and agents of shield could have be part
of our universe
did you get that read at all i mean yeah
that's that's that's the gambit here
right which is everything that has ever
been is possible
if you want daredevil back you get
daredevil back if you want spider-man
and his amazing friends back
you get spider-man and his amazing
friends back like everything
i want that man oh my god i could you
imagine you did some like live-action
version of that with old aunt may not
even like the current
like young oh my god i would totally
marry her aunt may but like
the old lady aunt may and [ __ ] and the
three of them living in the apartment
but it's
all [ __ ] live action oh
man disney plus is like what are you
going to say
subscribe i already subscribed i would
subscribe twice
if they did that [ __ ] show they
should open a category in disney plus
which is like pay what you feel
because at the end of loki i would have
been like here's all the money
here's a tip jar just tip it yeah yeah
that's what they need a little tip charm
like you sho you [ __ ] put it on the
glass here man
what did you think of the episode this
was definitely an episode where you
could not accuse it of
you know lollygagging or like nothing's
happening everything [ __ ] happened
in this episode including the dreaded
kiss that nobody wanted to see and stuff
um
that turns out to be like one of the in
instigating
factors of [ __ ] phase four um did you
think she was gonna do it
um yes yes i did um because i'm i'm of
two minds of the finale i'm of the mind
that i was also in last week
which is i don't really want to see kang
and of course they never call him kang
so he's just he
he who shall not be named or he remains
or um
you know he remains um
because as i said last week look that
character does not mean anything
to our protagonists you know he's a new
person they don't even know his actual
name
he's just a guy he's a really bad guy is
what loki tells
um uh tells mobius at the very end
and so for us to sit for about 15
minutes
and listen to the guy who we've never
met before talk
at us and our protagonist sit in chairs
and watch him talk
um felt a little it was like a kevin
smith movie man i'm like
that's why you loved it literally could
have made that episode
people just sat around and talked to
each other
it was tremendous after like all the
action the previous episodes it was it
was very
low tech um but that bug you that it's
like oh here's a new guy
um i mean it bugged me only because the
new guy you know by the time you get to
the end of a story
you want your villain and your heroes to
at the very least have met each other
to have some emotional attachment to
each other and understand what the
the other of them mean in the grand
scheme of things
and so in this finale you have kang
telling our quote-unquote heroes about
things that happen in the distant past
and things that may or may not happen in
the future but none of it really answers
their questions about
who they are what they want and what
they're trying to achieve
um so i felt a little like but i love
jonathan major so i will totally watch
that dude kind of go crazy for about 15
minutes
um and that was really yeah dude
performance from lovecraft country by
any stretch of the imagination
yeah no he's fantastic um but i was just
a little like
okay i mean if it's gonna be this and
yes they're gonna fight again loki and
sylvie because we need some action
otherwise it's just
you know 40 minutes of dudes talking so
they're going to fight for reasons that
don't quite make any sense for them to
fight but we need
something to happen um they're going to
kiss the kiss that i don't think anybody
was actually looking for
but we're going to get that um and then
you're going to get one last
sort of betrayal i guess and uh and then
we're gonna get what the future of the
mcu is
you know we're going to get that these
six hours have been setting up
the bad guy for the next movie um
and so the bad guy for the next movie
but the bad guy
and the thematic elements for like the
next
few movies on like this is how we get to
to secret wars
yes like for sure the amount of setup
that they did
in a disney plus show you know like five
years ago
they would have done it in a movie like
and it probably wouldn't have been
loki the movie or something like that
but here we are in a world where like
they're like no if you
part of our storytelling is now disney
plus
we're gonna do big things there so you
gotta [ __ ] stay
subscribed it was super [ __ ] smart
but it's so crazy that like the first
time around like
you know loki a loki was the doorway to
ever
to the next 10 years you know
um [ __ ] uh him and and
his deal with thanos in in the avengers
and whatnot um and here we are looking
at the next
you know 10 years or so because of the
loca
they're looking forward yeah yeah by
loki
my other my other thought i'm sorry go
ahead
i said i'm good i said it was [ __ ] by
loki twice in the best possible way
your other thought my other thought is
that
this has been six hours of
ultimately what is evil um
multi-dimensional
uh space karen who's asking to see the
manager
of a black-owned business because she's
unhappy with the way it's been run
he's a [ __ ] karen isn't he well
sylvie's the karen because she's the one
who won't take no for an answer
and take me to go see your manager and
the manager at the end of the universe
is kang
and she's unhappy with the way this
business is run and ultimately tries to
fire
the manager and does and so like
loki is the setup for [ __ ] around and
find out
like oh you wanted this i mean like the
tva what's that uh churchill quote
democracy is the worst form of
government except for all the others
like the tva is the worst form of
running universe
except for apparently all of the others
and
and it was a really crimson notion and
delivered through a smile when he was
just like
if you think i'm bad you know wait till
you meet the other me's
yeah and so she she would not take his
advice
she would not listen to anybody else
including the other loki he was like
maybe
he's right maybe we should just go home
and she's like i'm going to see the
[ __ ] manager and i'm going to get
somebody fired
and she does
and now we're all going to reap the
whirlwind of that decision
which is bad news um he
uh he's presented first as he who
remains which was
an old marvel character uh that had no
connection to kang necessarily but was
in the creator of the tva um
but he was presented more like immortus
which is
a version of kang in the comics but the
old wizard version the one that's like
oh
i have [ __ ] around and found out and
now i'm ready to be uh
and his outfit kind of looked like the
immortal he just didn't have the
gigantic [ __ ] hat
um but it was like i was blown away that
they gave us
you know he's not kang the the director
of the show is very clear being like
that's not kang that's he who remains
but
for all intents and purposes we got our
first taste
of jonathan majors in the role that he's
going to be playing apparently for the
next few years across a bunch of
different flags
yeah and and to be able to watch him
change the very the variance of his
performance on
on he who should not be named slasher
mortis kang because this one is crazy
this one has been by himself at a
citadel at the end of the at the end of
time
for as long as there has been a time you
know by himself
like looking at futures and and he's
lost his mind he's a broken man
and so when we see the kang who's on the
wall of the tva
like that's a different dude like that's
a dude who's got purpose and that's a
dude who's
you know conquered a bunch um and so i
look forward to seeing how he
accurate costume too like giant statue
looks like [ __ ] except for the head
beast looks like kang's [ __ ] costume
yeah so i'm i look forward to what's
next i just i wish that we had a little
bit more resolution
for the story that we watched as opposed
to a throw
to what we're gonna get next um you're
probably right but i didn't give a [ __ ]
a certain point i forgot it was a loki
show i was like out of the way this
guy's talking and
and you know as much as like i
appreciated his whole like you know he
he grew he became you know got better
like does what every
character you the main character you
want um he accomplishes he
he starts in one place gets to another
place but
by the time he got to the other place i
was like no no
kill the [ __ ] guy so i was glad that
sylvie
was not nearly as involved that she
remained
kind of loki at heart and uh and went
for the kill
because as if she didn't and it was just
like credits
[ __ ] that it's like we saved the world
you guys isn't that cool
i know no season two what did you think
of the season two stamp
um you know i think there's definitely a
bunch of questions that they set up to
answer
you know like what happened to sylvie
you know what is this new version the
tva
you know what what how did everything
change
underneath loki's feet in the time
between when he was with sylvia when he
bounced through that little portal and
ends up back in the tv headquarters you
know what is
is the rest of the world as different as
loki's world is
um and if that's a thing that they're
going to explore be it in loki season 2
or
these you know at least two or three
different movies we're going to see um
that's that's fascinating so yeah i i
look forward to season two simply to
wrap up you know
and and and cauterize those branch
stories
and tell us what the one true storyline
is going to be i also like how they
you know uh you always think uh oh i
think the show is gonna be this
you know based on you hear news like uh
they cast this person as kang
and so we're watching the show and
somewhere along the way everyone starts
going like kang's got to be the big bad
i think they're going to introduce
[ __ ] kang so you have an idea in your
head of like oh [ __ ] they're going to
bring him in he's going to look like the
[ __ ] character and stuff
and instead they introduced this really
cool notion of like
you're going to meet a lot of this
[ __ ] guy all sorts of different
flavors
like it never occurred to me they would
go that route
could you imagine you're the actor and
you receive the offer and like we want
you to play kang who's probably like
gonna be the next thanos like big bad or
something like that
and you'd be like oh right right on
that's a [ __ ] it's marvel of course
i'll [ __ ] do who do i gotta kill to
do it and [ __ ]
but then you find out that it's also
going to be like
creatively satisfying because you'll
probably get to give
five or six maybe 10 different
performances depending on how many
different variations
of kang that they wind up doing i felt
happy for him at that point man i was
like oh my god he's going to get to give
a bunch of different performances
that's the last time you'll see him play
the character
like like he did in that episode right
next
you're going to see these guys he's
going to be the conqueror um
or bigger than that yeah so i feel good
he's getting he has his own orphan black
now
where he gets to play like nine
different versions of the same character
thank god you watch current things
for a way to express it i'm like he get
to play many parts mark and you're like
yes kevin he's going to orphan black it
i'm like yeah
um overall uh loki uh
you know big ending so you know as long
as you end
well all is forgiven you know any any
lag
moments or something like that feels
like they could have got away with it in
less episodes but i ain't bitching you
know i was never bored
um but man like way to [ __ ] stick the
landing in fact they didn't even stick
the landing it's like
the ending is is bigger than the
previous
five episodes that that that we watched
it's almost like take the journey just
to get
to the ending because it sets up the
next like few years
of movie watching and tv watching for us
yeah i mean i feel like of of the three
marvel tv shows we've had
it's probably been the most consistently
understanding of what it is
you know like i feel like one division
for me and we talked about it both
together and when we had matt shakman on
the show
um the first three episodes took a
little bit for me too long
to reveal what the show was about um you
know we were doing a lot of the work
about whether or not this was about
grief and whether this was all wanda's
doing and what's happening with vision
and so forth and so on
i feel like falcon winter soldier was
um was hampered a bit by the fact that
they were in mid-production during a
pandemic and the show had been about a
viral pandemic
and so they had to do a lot of changing
in midstream and figuring out what the
bad guy was after
and like there were episodes that were
great and then some that just didn't
quite gel
whereas i feel like loki you know
regardless of how successful you feel
like it was
as a storytelling endeavor it knew what
it was the whole time
it didn't really flounder at all like it
was always going to be this kind of
workplace thing it was always going to
be the story
of loki's joining and and what it means
to be a loki
and and can a loki evolve or are we
always going to be this
um and so i think that in that regard it
stuck the landing a little firmer than
the other two shows have
um you're so much uh better at
expressing yourself than i am and or or
maybe it's just that you
give it way more thought like i just
come down to like oh my god i [ __ ]
loved it
and uh you can talk about you could talk
about it in a nuanced way which you know
ultimately is a positive
review but like it allows for
error or lag or something like that but
like i i would hate
like to to ask your review
as your lover you know like
someone sometimes a [ __ ] just
wants to hear like oh you're great and
you'd be like look the yeoman-like work
that you
put into the foreplay you know
definitely could have
could have been better but we got where
we needed to go
and by the time to my scrotum i felt
like you know
it was classic kev or whatever the [ __ ]
the first act was strong
you you're always good with the first
act the second
the middle there was no real climax in
the middle of the story but the
denouement
is where it was at so thank you
um we uh have a show uh coming out very
soon mark
in uh today is saturday night on
thursday night at midnight or friday
morning however you look at it
uh netflix will debut the part one of
masters of the universe revelation
um mr mr mark hamill who who essays the
role of our skeletor was just on uh
fallon the other night and they put up a
clip
that kind of shows like what he's after
uh
i mean grayskull duh but but what
specifically
um lots of other clips popping up online
there's a
uh ign clip coming up from mark's
episode
episode three um that takes place
on this on the um crystal c
and involves aquaticons so uh
that you can find online like any second
now and stuff
point is it's getting closer the review
embargo gets lifted on wednesday so
we'll start
hearing what the folks who write about
[ __ ] critics and whatnot
think about it i've heard early word and
it's very positive really really quite
nice people seem to like the show which
is
thank god for us um that being said
it drops july 23rd uh on july 24th
at jane salem bob secret stash in red
bank new jersey we're doing a
uh revel uh revelation celebration
uh which is uh basically a little kind
of uh weekend shindig party
where um you bring your kids you've got
kids that are like
10 and under mattel sent us a bunch of
action figures so
kids 10 and under get a figure problem
is most of the
kids coming are going to be 50 and over
[Laughter]
so those kids we got shirts for them
posters [ __ ] like that
but um griffin newman who plays our orco
um he's gonna join us at the secret
stash and then at night
mark is uh got something going on next
week is that why you're not gonna be
around
i do yeah my mom is in town so i'm doing
mom visiting things
oh i'll give it up for mark and his mom
me and my mommy are gonna go play um
well
griffin uh is gonna come and sit in for
mark so we're gonna do fat man beyond
next week
uh with griffin newman right here and
we'll probably do a lot of talking about
masters of the universe because it will
have dropped just like the two days
before or something like that so if you
go uh
uh i think there's a link somewhere the
jc probably
put up uh to join us at the secret stash
for the revelation celebration
and then at the smod castle site uh
tickets for next week's batman beyond
with griffin
it's on sale right now so next week or
this coming week is
all about masters of the universe which
i've been waiting for for two years
since we started working on this can't
wait for people to [ __ ] see it
however the biggest news of my year
drops on monday and has absolutely
nothing to do with masters of the
universe
i can't say much more about it but we
are in new jersey
are you gonna be the governor of new
jersey
um i'm gonna be here for a minute so
that's what monday's announcement
is is all about what not so it's a big
uh big week around here
uh for us uh for me personally as uh
especially
but um as much as monday's announcement
is gonna be big news and stuff
i cannot wait for for people to see the
episodes
i've been waiting for this long just to
watch
people good and bad because i'm sure
we'll get them both it's twitter
but to watch people react to the [ __ ]
show
like you know it's been handcrafted with
so much [ __ ] love and care and
attention
so i hope it's received that way i'm
sure based on what i've seen so far
early reactions
it is overwhelmingly received that way
and stuff
but you know i've got plenty of room for
people who are like [ __ ] you
because i've been dealing with that
since day one you know some people have
been attacking the show or whatever or
me for the show or whatever
um you know don't seem to understand
that like i've got
27 years experience dealing with people
telling me i suck at my job like
they've been telling me that since
clerks so i i'm i'm well aware but let
yet still here we are
so uh hopefully they'll give it a chance
but oh man
i can't wait to read people's reaction i
can't wait to
to see like i did a lot of press and i
just did two more interviews before i
came here to do the show tonight and um
you know each time i'm always like did
we stick the landing because generally
i'm being interviewed by people who are
like
it's the same refrain over and over i
watched this show growing up as a kid
this was my
show and stuff so mercifully we're being
interviewed by people who are like
already half in the bag and stuff for it
and you know all we had to do was not
drop their [ __ ] childhood and
apparently we didn't so
yay for us man but particularly yes
um but i give it up
to my good friend over there on the
screen behind me and whatnot because
i've been
si uh standing next to him sitting next
to him and standing next to him
uh for the last few years uh as quietly
without anybody really noticing while
we've been making jokes and [ __ ]
saying jeff's kiss t-shirt now on sale
um i've been quietly learning to become
a better writer and
all of that training came in handy like
you know on masters universe something
i'd never done episodic before
standing next to mark who like would
rewrite every movie
that we ever talked about and make them
better and [ __ ] like that
like you know made me better and so it
was a no-brainer to
drag him into this once we start working
on it and wait till you see his episode
i mean the good news is you get to see
every all the writers every one of us
have an episode in the first five so
you'll get to see the full
uh menu across the boards man but uh the
mark
has a line in episode three that
one of my favorites in the entire run of
the of the show
and it made it all the way through it's
like one of the best
and stupidest lines you'll ever hear in
your life
perfect because it's but it is coming
from skeletor and [ __ ] and then
mark hamill delivering it just made it
la i remember when we
we shot it we recorded it and the
powerhouse animation kids sent the first
animatic
so i i took a screenshot of it from you
know a little recording
on my phone and texted it to mark cause
i was like there's that stupid-ass line
you wrote
and [ __ ] luke skywalker just said it
man like that's nuts
when i saw when i saw that episode the
final product
that was the one that made me both like
giddy and weepy all at the same time
which was
he [ __ ] said the line it's still in
there
it is so stupid and i love it today
that puts you amongst giants because you
know across the body of his career
many times mark has been like i can't
believe i have to say a line this stupid
joey said it on the set of jay and son
of bob strike back many years ago
but he probably said it when george was
like say this thing about power
converters
you know and he was like
stupid [ __ ] but i'll i'm getting paid
i'll [ __ ] say it
you stand shoulder to shoulder with
george lucas for that reason my friend
hot damn
and it's all because of you my friend we
uh
we did a we recorded before i left los
angeles
um i got together with all the writers
and we did uh uh commentary tracks
um for the youtube channel here so when
the episodes you've watched all the
episodes
um we'll put them up probably maybe
we'll wait till monday so
give people a chance to watch friday
saturday sunday so the following monday
we'll put up the commentary tracks and
and there's
i do one by myself for episode one then
it's me and dia for two
me and mark for episode three me and tim
for episode four
and me and eric for episode five so you
get all sorts of inside info about the
episodes and whatnot
um and you could watch along with you
know just time it up with the show and
watch it and even if you're not watching
it with the show
they're good deep dive listens and stuff
so uh look for that
uh next week i'll give you another heads
up and stuff uh next week's episode
uh anything else we should do up front
or should we dive into the
into the news of it all i just want to
remark on how amazed that i am that your
robe
traveled across the country with you
i you know i [ __ ] i got dressed for
day one of spot castle
and then i was like what the [ __ ] you
own the theater so
ever since then i was like i'm gonna
dress like a dress at [ __ ] home so
yeah i came comfy as [ __ ] man
most impressive looking forward to this
tonight like i got up today i had a lot
of [ __ ] to do for a saturday it just
kind of stacked up that way
um but i was so looking forward to this
because i was like
i'm gonna [ __ ] go we're gonna talk
about [ __ ] loki and [ __ ] like that
and finally put that goddamn shirt up
for sale
right now ladies and gentlemen help me
prove jordan wrong
i kept saying like oh my god like you
know as much as there was [ __ ] that i i
had to do
this was the thing i was most looking
forward to because a it's always a fun
show to do and stuff
b now the component of doing it like
live at smod castle makes it fun as well
like adds another element a little
another layer to it
but also i was like i'm going to wear my
[ __ ] robe
it's a good job when you just wear your
robe you know it's me and a priest
that's
it you know maybe maybe people on a porn
set but generally speaking
robes are discouraged in the real world
but they're [ __ ] dope i feel like a
jedi when i wear this and [ __ ]
everybody who gets to wear robe in the
real world is blessed you're all blessed
you john holmes the pope everybody's got
a gift
that's right that's real well [ __ ] i
don't have the gift that john holmes had
at all
but i do have a robe excellent
uh news uh we have some let me tell you
something kids mark bernard
before it became a [ __ ] scribe chief
scribe
and stuff like you read about in the
bible he was a guy that used to follow
the news and [ __ ] he used to make the
news report on the news
mr mark bernard's got news and his
[ __ ] blood comes out his pores i've
stood next to the man he smells like
[ __ ] newsprint and stuff
so guess what he went and collected what
little news there is for us to
to do and and here's mark bernard with
the news give it up for mark bernard in
the newshound
[Applause]
for the first time in a very long time
we have box office news to talk about
yeah that's that's been happening again
recently i remember
that somebody said a number and i was
like the [ __ ]
and it really makes me feel inadequate
because i never hit those [ __ ]
numbers
so during the pandemic i felt like a box
office king
because they were like the box office
with a thousand bucks i was like yoga
hosers made that kind of money
it's real rules and [ __ ] where
everybody's spending a bunch of loot and
stuff and we're starting to see six
figures hold on
somebody just went to the bathroom it's
mod castle
and the bathroom is right next to the
stage so let's see if we can hear if
it's number one
or number two
that's number two ladies and gentlemen
wow
well played one when when they come out
make sure you give them the shameful
look like how dare you
void
um yes black widow is doing uh
remarkably well at the box office
it's already made 214 million dollars
worldwide
um it opens to 80 million dollars in the
states it made something like
60 million maybe more on disney plus
so did you go in a theater or you watch
it at home
i wanted to go in the theater i could
not make it so i just watched it in my
living room
i didn't ask your [ __ ] intentions
don't tell us don't don't glide in that
way yes or no did you watch it at home
or theater
once got nothing to do with it buddy
what did you do
i you know i'd love to support a
theatrical and [ __ ] but i was like
greedy i just got up at three in the
morning i was like oh what the [ __ ] am i
gonna do i was like holy [ __ ] black
widow and i smoked weed and watched that
so five in the morning
then i watched it again and [ __ ] so i
couldn't do that at the movie theater
they would never let me smoke weed
at three in the morning either you have
to buy your own movie theater
yeah no well i'm halfway there see
that's all you need you show up in your
robes smoke your own weed watch it when
you want to watch it
i was a part of that box office i'm i'm
uh happy to report
you know i put a hold on
it's all for you damien
[Laughter]
smod castle's a place where you get
cheered for [ __ ]
and it was [ __ ] you were in there a
little too long for pp my friend
it's the use of the word peepee that
makes it delicious
did you hear that and you were just
playing us you're like
shy bladder oh my god so you normally
have a shy bladder and then i was like
everybody listen and you're like what
the [ __ ] bro
[ __ ] stone leave me alone
[Laughter]
all right mark uh with so what black
widow made a lot of money
marvel's doing well big [ __ ] news
uh as did space jam 2 made 32 million
dollars in its opening weekend
space jam that just opened this weekend
yep
and it made 32 million 32 million and
it's also on hbo max
i was going to say once again this is a
program you could literally watch at
home
yes and you have to pay extra if you
have hbo max you don't have to drop
another dime on it
but people still went out the box office
is [ __ ] in the future man uh
probably not so much for big movies like
that
but now people are kind of spoiled right
like i'm one of those people where i'm
like i'm gonna watch that [ __ ] at home
which i did with black widow um
and this is something they've talked
about for years like why can't it be
in theaters for people that want it and
at home for people that want it
and for years the common wisdom was like
because if it's at home who the [ __ ]
gonna go to the theater but as we're
seeing
32 million dollars worth of people will
go see space jam 2
even though they could literally watch
it on hbo max if they have it
so yeah i guess but both can exist i
mean there's
there's something to be said for the
novelty now of being able to go back to
the movie theater
you know the people who haven't been
able to go for a long time and you know
parents and kids and that
the the experience of returning i think
is counting for a lot of these grosses
but it's clear that there is a dual path
for this stuff going forward
and and perhaps the the extended window
we used to get
six months between a theatrical release
and something
some version on home video is shrinking
faster and faster like quiet place two
oh someone's gonna take a [ __ ] or
another bug making a run
the bug is back mark he's making his
second run
this is his return to the jedi he's
going back to the death star
anyway i don't want to be like mike
pence where this [ __ ] lands on my head
[Applause]
and then defines me for the next [ __ ]
few nights
um what uh what other news mark
um we well there's uh emmy nominations
came out this past week yeah there were
a bunch for
for shows that we like there was a bunch
for [ __ ] that nerds are fond of
um mandalorian got the tied for the most
nominations tied with the crown 24
nominations
uh including cutest ever
greatest ever
little yoda puppet man like just
that's that's [ __ ] emmy gold right
there
you know it's it's marketing gold
they're selling toys like crazy and [ __ ]
but
that's the way into the cold-hearted
emmy viewers [ __ ] internal man just
like baby yoda
oh man they're so hardcore about they'll
be like it's [ __ ] grogu you idiot
it's gonna be baby yoda i should that
[ __ ] a bunch of
awards not just nominations i bet you
they wind up walking away with stuff
what's the weirdest nomination they got
the waiters
well i mean they got a bunch of
technical [ __ ] but
giancarlo esposito got nominated for off
gideon
timothy oliphant and carl weathers got
nominated as best guest actor
did not what yeah
um i agree with all the picks though
like i agree with uh
allah fantastic getting the nod and
[ __ ] um
and uh apollo creed getting a nod and
and then a uh bugging out getting a nun
most people know him from breaking bad
and [ __ ] but
he's always bugging him
one division got 23 nominations um
elizabeth olsen and paul bettany both
got nominations for best actor
catherine hahn got one they bet they
those two better get nominated her
especially
you know i i know she's got stiff
competition but she should win that was
an incredible performance
still like [ __ ] makes me tear up when
i think about her at the end and [ __ ]
she's a great crier you know what i'm
saying like
there's some people that cry so well and
[ __ ] where you like they
emote and you feel their [ __ ] pain i
would
it'd be tough to be in a relationship
with a crier that powerful
because anytime they cried you'd be like
you're right we're [ __ ]
i'm sorry i didn't mean it she does that
silent cry thing where she's just like
you know and then before a single noise
comes out all the agony and [ __ ] in the
world
and she's so pleasant in real life you
know but that but i guess that's acting
ladies and gentlemen director kevin
smith
stupid thought i was like it's crazy
mark she acts like a witch
in real life not a witch
i'm glad i'm glad for her man she
deserves all the nods him too man
like i'm sure there was a point in the
proceedings you know granted there's
marvel so they're like anything you say
kevin foggy
but you know these are him more than her
you know most cats back when he's a
little bit older
that dude never wanted to be a tv person
you know what i'm saying he wanted to be
a movie [ __ ] star
so even if it's a marvel tv show it's
still a tv show and there's still a bias
out there which is [ __ ] nuts
but that bias is getting erased when
like a dude like paul bettany
could walk over to like a marvel tv show
and walk away
with a huge [ __ ] hemi knot just one
more [ __ ] piece of tin to put up on
the
on the shelf so any sort of like bias
anti-streaming anti-tv
bias probably just long gone at this
point remember like in when we were kids
and even up through the beginning of my
career
very clear differentiation between tv
and [ __ ] movies and if movie people
did tv they were like my career is
[ __ ]
and now it's like look at this [ __ ] i'm
sweeping award nominations and [ __ ] like
that and i was wearing
makeup the whole time [ __ ] you that's my
vision you know yeah i think it started
the shift began with true detective
when mcconaughey and woody harrison
showed up on hbo
it was like oh damn all right no they're
not just like movie actors but movie
actors in their prime
like award like oscar winners are
showing up to be on tv and then that was
kind of the floodgates and then
everybody realized
the good work is being done um in great
part for actors
on television yeah you get more time
with a [ __ ] character
you know like nobody's ever like
thinking about giving elizabeth olsen
awards for
the marvel movies she's done so far even
though she's done great work in him and
stuff but like
this you got to see like her craft to
performance over the course of all those
episodes
give a story arc you know she gets to
see so much more of that character
and she gets to fill like that
performance with with subtle nuances and
[ __ ]
so at that point you're like my god what
an amazing actress in a way that you
never would have
just by seeing her in like end game or
something like that
yeah um good for all them man and good
for us in a world where they treat this
[ __ ] seriously
that means they'll keep doing so used to
be there you know go back a few years a
lot of people bitching like nobody
[ __ ] likes comic book nothings
and now they [ __ ] do so you know i'm
not gonna say
that all began with heath ledger but
once heath ledger won an oscar and ship
were like oh [ __ ] i guess this comic
book [ __ ] should be treated seriously
and now they're treating it seriously
awards wise what else got nodded besides
those two
um a week after hbo canceled lovecraft
country it got 18
nominations uh including for best drama
outstanding series i love that show it's
sad when they said they weren't going to
go again
what else got nominated the boys my
friend
the boys hey man outstanding drama
that's i mean 100
behind i don't think this is a hot take
for me to say like oh my god i co-signed
that 100
but that's a show that the old emmys
would have not acknowledged like makes
sense to me that they're like oh we like
wand division
i would have it would have not surprised
me if they were like and the boys got
nothing because they're just having a
good time [ __ ] them
so instead the emmy's now like
we're having a good time so [ __ ] come
in and they get nodded too how many
nominations they get
they got five um four of them are
technical nominations like you know
sorry three of them are they got an
outstanding writing nomination and an
outstanding drama series
i i [ __ ] but both of those are well
earned i would have given one to
uh what's the lead guy's name um
the guy anthony anthony star or
um huey anthony star plays
homelanders real name is anthony starr
all right if somebody was like what's
[ __ ] homelander's name and i'm gonna
pull your brands out i would in a
million years
i wouldn't land on anthony or star i'd
be like oh matt damon
like he just seems like a no it's not
mad damn but he seems like he should
have a name like that
it seems like a man i gotta remember
that anthony starr he's amazing i would
have [ __ ] given him a nod that
performance this year was [ __ ]
nuts yeah he [ __ ] himself he blew
himself and then he
jerked off on the city and give that guy
the emmy give him all the emmys
one of the technical categories was best
[ __ ] shot over the city
i think that's a different award show is
uh kripke is he's the guy that gets the
nod for the for the writing
um it depends on the episode that got
nominated i think
you know kripke will share in it but
whatever credited writer got the
got the on-screen credit will be the one
who wins the enemy i like him he's a
good guy i interviewed him before
he's uh he's having a good time with
that show uh as
what else got nominated anything we give
a [ __ ] about [ __ ] and winner soldier
uh got five nominations the weirdest of
them
is yes let's talk about the weird one
because one of these nods is not like
the other
yes um anthony mackie nor
sebastian stan didn't get nominations
neither did carl lumley
who did amazing [ __ ] work as
isaiah bradley i thought he was a sure
man that was an easy nod but he didn't
get a nod
no but you know who did don cheadle
don cheadle who was in 98 seconds
this guy was was going back going like
what episode was he
and he was like in the opening credits
of episode one right
now he's in he's in like the third scene
here and then he [ __ ] took off
and the emmys were like brilliant give
him a nod
give it to the cheats um i saw he said
something about it
did you see that i didn't now what do
you say
he was like i'm as baffled as everyone
else
that's not the exact quote but he too
indicated that he's like i
i have no [ __ ] idea he's going but
thanks
not so bad but weird imagine being so
good at your job that they're like that
[ __ ] he deserves a nod
for that 90 seconds yeah like what was
it
uh when judy dench won for shakespeare
and love she had something like 13
minutes of screen time maybe
eight it might have been this is
i can beat that in two notes
um good for him man what do anything
else get nodded we give a [ __ ] about
uh cobra kai [ __ ] hey i do care about
that a lot
like an ex-girlfriend yes outstanding
comedy series
i'm so glad my wife doesn't watch the
show
you care about ex-girlfriends but you
care about cobra cox i've seen you cry
over cobra guy
what did they get for writing uh
outstanding comedy series
uh comedy there's nothing
about cobra kai um it is a very sweet
show i would never
think to put it in the comedy series
yeah i
don't know why drama to me but whatever
as long as i get a nod that's great
um i don't even know but if i have to
guess it's like
blackish and vegan the flight attendant
and stuff like that
um anything else we care about that's it
that's it the one thing that i did the
two shows there was
i'm sorry go ahead i just had nothing to
do with genre but did
uh kate winslet get nodded for mayor yes
i like that show that was so [ __ ]
good she was so amazing in it
yeah mayor is probably gonna clean up
wawa pretzels
all the time in california
and [ __ ] we do have a few wawa's out
near us and stuff but they don't carry
the [ __ ] president just like in
florida they got wawa's and every time i
go see my mom i get so excited because
i'm like the [ __ ] pretzel
but in florida they're like too hot for
pretzels so they don't go out of the
chip but now i'm in jersey man [ __ ]
wawa pretzels i've already gained
10 pounds eating wawa [ __ ] pretzels
so i'm like well wow
[Music]
yeah i was a little uh upset that
sponsored by wawa pretzels ladies and
gentlemen
uh yeah mythic quest didn't get any love
and i love mythic quest
um and neither did for all mankind
you watched mythicquest yeah what is it
about i see it on
apple tv but they've never done a good
job of selling it to me
same thing with they never did a good
job of selling ted lasso to me you're
the one that made me watch said last
time it changed my life
so maybe i'm messing up with mythic
quest i'm sleeping on it what is it
about
mythic quest it's a workplace comedy set
in a video game developers
studio
who's in it um rob mcelini from it's
always
sunny in philadelphia is sort of kind of
the lead
um and he also co-created it and you
know writes every fourth episode or
whatever it is
but it's it has i'm not gonna say it has
nothing to do with video games because
it does
but it's not reliant upon your knowledge
of video games
we got another pisser mark well dude
call me when the [ __ ] show up
the pisser's whatever
is it uh got sweetness to it has got
heart like ted lasso is it just funny
it's uh it's got a bit of both it's got
a bit of both and they they did this one
episode about midway through the first
season
which has nothing to do at all with the
main drama it's a pure standalone
episode with uh jake johnson
from new girl slash spiderman into the
spiderverse
and uh kristen miliotti
who uh who was in palm springs
and the uss mcallister episode of of
black mirror
on hbo that i watched a few episodes of
yeah
and it's just this pure standalone story
about these two people
um complete polar opposites like she's
the queen of death and
despair and all that and he's a
happy-go-lucky dude who just wants to
make video games
and it's their relationship and how it
sort of grows and twists and and warps
with success and with failure and how
they as individuals survive it
and it's you know 30 minutes long and it
tells a complete life story
and it's incredibly well done very very
sweet
incredibly funny and the whole show kind
of has that same
vibe it's not quite ted lasso because
ted lasso is also about
hope in a way that that mythic quest
isn't but i think they
they are they're kind of the same cloth
in that i could give a [ __ ] about
european football
but i love ted lasso and i don't know
anything about
making video games at that level but i
kind of love this show
high praise i'm gonna check it out uh
ted lasso drops next week same time as
masters of the universe so i've seen
masters many times i'll be watching ted
lasso
indeed and cheering for masters while i
watch
at lasso and stuff um i can't wait but
you've actually done a better job of
selling that show
than they did so i'll give it a chance
next time i see it your app will give me
some of your monies or just like give me
this [ __ ] for free
they should [ __ ] hire you as the
spokesperson man but like nobody wants
to watch a four-minute commercial you
know where you're just
playing about the episode and you deep
dive like you do but that's how you sell
it to me i'm [ __ ] like
um uh is that it for our emmy news
that's it for the emmy news um
congratulations to all those
[ __ ] winners indeed
um our boy matt shakman who he's not a
boy and he's not ours but he was on the
show so he's a
friend of the pod wait wait a [ __ ]
back track
um he's the fox he's the he's the
talented boy that did one division
correct indeed um
and a very [ __ ] important job i read
he's making a star trek movie for jj
yeah he's making the next star trek it's
him that's what happened
you do good things you get rewarded now
go make one division
that's awesome for him man that
monovision show is [ __ ] dynamite and
he definitely had a lot to do with it
and stuff so i'm sure he'll do a great
job with star trek they say anything
about the plot
they said nothing about the plot nor
does anybody know about the cast
like none of those guys will jj's kids
be coming back
right like there's there's i don't think
there are any deals at this point
um to retain them they would all be
brand new negotiations to get everybody
back
and i don't know if you get everybody
back you know um so i don't
it's unclear what the storyline for the
movie is i don't think it is any longer
the time travel story that they wanted
to do where
uh where chris pines kirk uh chris
hemsworth right he's to bring meet up
and go on an adventure with his dad um i
don't think that's happening anymore
but it's also unclear what this is going
to be
um but i hope you get everybody back you
would need the
the cass jj's kids to uh make that
version
a little 90s joke give it up for robin
harris
um uh yeah man good for him matt
shackman killing it and [ __ ]
absolutely um a little bit of casting
news
unclear what he's going to be playing
but antonio banderas
is now going to be an indiana jones 5.
oh [ __ ] a all right what's in boots
i mean he's done many [ __ ] things but
also pushing boots i mean photo of uh
phoebe waller bridge on set
today on the internet that got me
excited not not because i'm like [ __ ]
phoebe wallabridge although i do like
her very much uh her outfit got me
excited and not that i'm a wardrobe
fiend but it indicated
a time period that i might have been
alive
for so all of the raiders of the lost
ark movies like you know all happen
before i'm born and [ __ ] but this one
looks like it happens late 60s early 70s
am i incorrect um there's at least some
piece of that
where uh yeah i had heard like late 60s
but if it even broaches into
uh pre-disco i'm here for that
oh you ain't kidding well actually like
i was born august 1970 so that means i
was conceived
november 69 so there's a good chance i'm
in the movie
but just in my mom's stomach at that
point and [ __ ]
or in my dad's nut sack excellent
yes the winter of love as we call
november i'm 64.
mark when i'm when i'm alive for them
like i
like i enjoyed mad men but when they
finally got to like 1970 i was like
everybody shut up i'm alive now
maybe they'll catch me in the back of
that screen maybe they'll reference me
um what else we got um speaking of
photos
snapped on a set um we did get a look
at some flash slash colon flashpoint
set photography that very excitingly
featured a certain batmobile that
belonged to a certain
michael keaton oh we're seeing graphics
i'm seeing them on my screen but i don't
know if you guys see them on your screen
can you put them up here in the
castle if not kids you're missing out
because [ __ ]
it's a picture of of the tim burton
batmobile
the batmobile as far as uh
yeah oh there's the screen there you can
see
look at that [ __ ] man what else give us
the other pictures banff man
look what you're seeing backstage on
banff man with his green screen and [ __ ]
that is side camera good thing he has a
shirt on jc usually works shirtless as
well
the bat cave they're recreating it with
a lot of grief
wow wow man it's 1989 all over again
is that it any other pictures there was
a picture of supergirl
um who i can't remember the actors
playing
oh that's awesome look at that right on
i've heard rumors that she is like you
know since this is of course
the multiverse that she's
not standing in for henry cavill but in
this universe
it's a super girl not superman
i've heard everything's coming up
multiverses
really is man like talk about like the
one idea in the [ __ ] water and the
environment like that up in the ether
like studios or both comic book
companies making movies they're like oh
yeah now it's time to
show the weirdness and [ __ ] like it's
it's so
is the bug back
where i don't want to kill him
oh my god that means he's in me now
don't kill him don't kill him just get
him out of here take him outside
give it up for ernie everybody castle
keeper
bug saver ernie o'donnell
ernie got off stage and was like
day one of the show put him on your bike
just let it go just
just let it go just be quiet just go
ahead fly
it'll be all right um what else what
were we talking about or where are we
going next
um we are next going to a little bit of
news on a television program that i had
worked on
called the continental um oh that's the
the show is set in john wickland the
wikiverse
it is indeed um when i was working on it
it was supposed to be a tv series
um we had broken eight episodes we began
writing them
and then uh the powers that be decided
that it would now become
three 90-minute tv movies
um which will now be directed uh the
first and last by
albert hughes one of the famed hughes
bros
brothers there's an allen and albert
hughes from
indeed from hell and you know albert had
done book of eli
um they did both of them did dead
presidents back in the day i think there
was there was a big blow up
madness to society was that theirs um i
believe it was too
i believe it was two they they've had a
very good run they've been around for a
minute
indeed but it's not on this just one of
them just one of them
um and if you the boys and girls at home
don't know the continental is set 40
years before the events of the john rick
movies against the backdrop of new york
in the 1970s
and it's going to follow or it's said to
follow that in the 1970s
you were around for that my attention
now because
during the show so wait a second the
idea is this is the wikiverse before
wick
yes you know the the it is a prequel and
according to the hollywood reporter
which i cannot confirm nor deny
their plot information the series is
said to follow a much younger version of
winston
the character played by ian mcshane on
the big screen and in the prequel
winston is a hitman who creates a safe
haven
for unsavory characters like himself
namely the continental
oh right on does that sound like what
you were working on
uh it does it does not seem like they
are far off
i cannot confirm nor deny
is it the same like since you guys are
working on a series
and it becomes like a series of tv
movies instead
it's not like they're like we're
throwing all that [ __ ] out and starting
from scratch they
used all the [ __ ] that you guys worked
on or you don't know um
i don't know but if i had to guess it's
just a matter of
of uh synthesizing of saying you were
gonna do eight hours and now we're going
to do
you know five hours and so
what if this is you know where along the
line can we end the story
how much of it do we need to tell the
story but you don't get to have all of
it
so start cutting fat and occasionally
meat and muscle
um so i had to guess they just truncated
it probably the first half of what would
have been the entire series
totally a guess i don't know anything
they call it kind of [ __ ]
who's doing that show you know uh
that'll be stars lionsgate
is the studio and stars will be the
network right on
all right well we got a minute before
that happens uh what else is going on
um that is it from the news front my
friend
are you you're kidding really the week
was all about loki dude everybody was
easy ready to clear out clear the
[ __ ] trap we're talking about loki
that's true very true uh hey banff man
what is uh what are the folks online
saying did we miss anything bam bam
uh it doesn't look like there's uh no it
feels like
we haven't missed anything online i mean
the only thing we did miss
and i was reminded um very acutely
by the music that was playing in the
smod castle as i was waiting to
to join the fun that the great biz
marquis
passed away that's true lost bismarck at
age 57
is that it yeah complication of diabetes
yeah um uh not dissimilar from the way
my
father passed away um one of my favorite
rappers when i was a kid
you you got what i need
are you saying he's just a friend
you say hey
oh
old school fans he had another track
called picking boogers from back in the
day the [ __ ] book
[Music]
uh that's right the track picking
boogers we used to love that in high
school
i'll let him go he's got a right to life
he just wants to be
he wants hey banff man what's up um
we did uh did i think it was this week
we saw that
deadpool little teaser commercial i
didn't actually watch it but people on
the chat are talking about it
like deadpool's in the mcu he's talking
to
blue character
yeah it was a commercial for free guy um
with a trailer reaction
where they got taika who's in free guy
to sit next to
ryan reynolds is deadpool and can i uh
can i
add a little perspective to that please
do can i
grab on to a little their glory their
shine
um i uh well [ __ ] i was about to say
something i shouldn't
there's an ad that i know an assistant
director i don't know what project he's
working on right now but
i talked to him like every day and um
his name is shane and shane was the ad
on that
spot really picture he was like i was
like talking about the [ __ ] i was
like anybody see the free guy
spot with ryan reynolds and he was like
um
oh you mean this and he pulled up a
picture of him sitting next to
deadpool where korg was sitting in the
spot
i was like get the [ __ ] out of here like
you you did that spot he's like yeah
he's going i work with ryan i've worked
with him a few times
and uh he's number one he goes he's he's
very nice like you and i was like well
he's got me beat because he's [ __ ]
canadian man they're
they just come out the shoot super like
sorry you know so
real nice and stuff but he was like um
this
is what i found incredibly charming
because i was like that's
him in the suit and he's like yeah and
he was in full [ __ ] suit he had the
mask on and everything
and i was like i mean you could
literally put anyone in that suit and
just dub the line he goes he loves doing
it so he puts on the suit
and he [ __ ] did it and then after
they did the spot and he's like
we shot 10 different scripts like he's
just happy to do each one
i was like can he see out of the mask
and like totally but the pieces pop out
so if he needs to breathe and stuff like
that
they pop him in and just go through all
the spots and he said but like a lot of
the lines that were in the final spot
like came later on he's like we didn't
even record some of those jokes i guess
he thought of them later on and
the ability you have with the character
like deadpool is you can replace all the
[ __ ] dialogue because there's no
moving lips or something like that
right so he said that like they shot all
the spots
and then after he was done he's still in
costume so he was like
give me the the shout outs and he did a
list of like
shout outs to sick kids hey this is
deadpool feel better and a funny joke
and [ __ ] like that
super [ __ ] sweet he's going on to
hour three wearing the [ __ ] suit
and he goes like i'm wearing the suit so
if anybody like wants to take pictures
like
in the whole [ __ ] crew got to come up
and take pictures with the dude and it's
him
wearing the [ __ ] suit he could
literally hire somebody to wear the suit
and just stand off camera and be like
i'm deadpool but he's [ __ ] literally
sitting there wearing a suit i was so
impressed
by that work ethic man i thought that
was really [ __ ] cool give it up for
ryan reynolds what a good guy
because if season one of the mandalorian
has taught us anything is that yes
anyone could be in the suit yeah but
not anyone could be in that suit um
that my god this fucker's still right
here
look at him he's so fascinated by this
show don't get defensive he grows up
like
i'm gonna let them sit right there um
that spot looks good though that was a
funny spot and uh that
actually looks good it's finally coming
out after all this is august i believe
um i asked uh shane i was like what's
the [ __ ]
korg there and he goes what are you
stupid
so tycho wasn't there you can you know
obviously it's a big
cg character and you could do his voice
anywhere and stuff but
ryan ryan is there wearing the suit ryan
shows up
i'm reynolds [ __ ] will wear the suit
taika ytt will not wear the [ __ ] suit
uh what else we got um well we got our
second ad
the first ad was about getting it hard
the second ad is about getting them
smooth
oh kids that means we're done with the
news give it up for mark bernard and he
gave you the news
you just you're missing this whole like
[ __ ]
triumph of the spirit moment here mark
this [ __ ] bug will not be denied
i don't know what he wants but i'm half
tempted to just cut my hand open and
feed him the blood
um
you got what i need
um he's just coming and he won't stop
don't do it er don't
a little piece of paper no no no he
won't jump on that he's threatened by
the sword of power
yeah see if you can get him again don't
kill him this is bad
this is this i thought it was the same
one
there's another one what the [ __ ] kind
of place you running here
i'm [ __ ] going on yelp i'm seeing
bugs
all over smart guzzler um
possible for the second half of this
[ __ ] mark who's paying
uh the second half of this [ __ ] is
paid for the good folks at manscaped
oh we love manscape ladies and gentlemen
manscape makes your dick look
presentable for heaven's sakes
and it makes your balls smell good
what's the website that we're sending
them to as we speak about this
we are sending them to manscape.com
and use the code fatman20 to get 20
off plus free shipping with the
codefatman20 manscape.com
can you believe there was a time in
human history where they didn't give a
[ __ ] what your [ __ ] pubes looked like
now thanks to the good folks at
manscaped
we could do that we could get up and be
like this shit's out of control
and you could put a comb through it put
a [ __ ]
razor through it a shaver electric
shaver that works on your head mark even
uses it on his head is that correct
i did i touched myself up today before i
came on the camera
although i didn't know we were doing
robe casual so i maybe didn't need to
it's always robe casual man
that's paper gentle enough for your nuts
strong enough for your [ __ ] head man
that's what manscape brings to you that
and
you ever think you'd [ __ ] use that in
your life you'll never stop once you
start putting it on man
i took some of that ball turner i was
like yeah [ __ ] rubbed it in my balls
i was like
why that i feel like a man today
i feel fresh my wife was just like your
balls look much
toner like thank you thank the good
folks
at manscaped um i'm sure they have
proper copy there mark what are they
telling us
they do um i will again read their uh
their scintillating copy
and again it's dirtier than you'd think
it would be for an ad
the sun's out bums are out but hopefully
your pubes
are not out
is that a thing do people go to the
beach and pull their pubes out to the
side to be like
maybe you got too much bush for your
speedo and shit's creeping out the side
yeah you don't want that so thank you
manscape
also flip-flop season is upon us or
here's something
don't wear a [ __ ] speedo
they're not a sponsor so [ __ ] them but
uh
but if you're going to work you know
you're goddamn right you need some
[ __ ] manscapes man they'll take care
of you
they'll pull all that unwanted hair out
of there man this ain't none of that
depilatory nonsense
this is good old-fashioned cutting hairs
ladies and gentlemen
right next to your dick and balls
sounds well it is
a little bit of adventure every [ __ ]
time you use the manscape product you
don't know what's gonna happen down
there
and then when you're finished you're
like oh what a relief manscape the
adventure
uh they also and i'm only going to say
this because this is the thing they're
pushing because i don't want to get in
the way of landscape the adventure
because this sounds
like the best choose your own adventure
book i've ever read
um but they've also launched um 2.0
shears for nail grooming because you
don't want your [ __ ] flip-flop season
is upon us and you don't want those
post-pandemic toenails
carving people up on the beach so it is
for
elf i was like what are dick nails
what is this i didn't know about this
that is a completely different condition
wow man's game is like we're not just
about your balls we like your fingertips
too
they're making you clip your toenails
that's pretty sweet good for them
absolutely is that good is that what
we're promoting we're promoting their
performance package 4.0 which includes
the new lawnmower 4.0 which again for
your ball hair and your head hair if you
want
um and then you've also got the [ __ ]
weed whacker
to chop the worst weeds up your nose and
in your ear
and then crop preserver boom and then
the new shears which take care of your
luxury four piece nail kit
featuring tempered steels tools and
tweezers and round point scissors and
finger clippers and a grip nail file man
just [ __ ] get everything
sorted on your body to take your clothes
off
and show people without shame manscaped
you really put it on front street this
is like advertising for dummies you're
like this is for when you take your
clothes off
you look hairy and stupid unless you're
right you're absolutely right where do
we send to mark how can they get this
[ __ ] amazing deal
you can get 20 off plus free shipping
with the code fatman20
manscape.com that's 20 off plus free
shipping
with the code fatman20 at manscape.com
tame that summer swamp in your pants
with manscaped
i'm [ __ ] stealing that line man
totally going home after the show i'm
gonna tell my wife tame that
swamp in my pants
go back to your smod castle and jerk off
i was like i already did that and the
flies showed up
yes the bugs uh we thank the good folks
at manscape
uh for sponsoring fat man beyond man
wonderful company
that still believes in our show indeed
all right ladies and gentlemen we come
to that point in the evening everybody
[ __ ] loves man
uh this is where we do the q a of it all
this is where we find out what you're
thinking
and uh and do that and last week we did
it and
normally when we do it in california um
you know we give out prizes and [ __ ]
last week was the first time we did it
here at spot castle and we didn't give
out prizes
um because we were like [ __ ] running
late on that show with another show
afterwards and stuff
but now like you know we're [ __ ] at a
leisurely pace it's you know [ __ ]
only 10
30 and [ __ ] like that so i think we
could like
we could do prizes for this one man
like some [ __ ] you got some [ __ ]
i i do i got some i i think i
do got some [ __ ] like uh hey earn castle
keeper and you know there he is castle
keeper ernie o'donnell ladies and
gentlemen
that uh
that trunk in the back like the the
bucket
thing that's the back of all the gear
that one into the micro they can hear
the one that's in the back of the josh's
gear that one yeah
yeah the one that we're gonna have to
climb yes exactly can you open that and
grab
uh a shirt one of the
plastic figurines as well
and and then don't say what and then um
then one other
thing there's other things yes how many
do you want how much stuff
we just need three three three questions
sweet man look at ernie's all over that
all right so we'll have some
cool [ __ ] to give away these are props
one-of-a-kind props normally we give
away tickets to things or
or premiums and stuff like that uh but
we got a bunch of props
from yoga hosers backstage the audience
just left mark
just give them money give them give them
a 20 dollar village
yeah like i paid 50 bucks you give me a
[ __ ] yoga hoser's treat [ __ ] this
um all right so let's uh let's dive one
question first
i think that's so smart hey banff man
why don't you come in here and help us
out
hey uh
i wanted to say or something real quick
to all the people in
chat asking if i have a white durag on
it's not it's a baseball hat
i was wearing it backwards and so chat
for like 10 minutes on youtube was like
can we get a
fat man beyond do-rag i'd buy that it
would go well with my jeff's kiss shirt
so i had to i had to address
this um let's uh let's get that [ __ ]
going
a fat man beyond do-rag i'll wear one if
you'll wear one
i won't i heard a [ __ ] up it's got to
be a positive hopefully it was about our
show
um okay uh banff man do me a favor and
pick a question
from the folks online before we open it
up to the real live folks right here at
this podcast
all right uh we had a lot of good ones
tonight but my favorite was from old
mcmoney uh who wanted to know
uh or who said it's my 42nd birthday and
my question
is what hero or villain
would you have planned your birthday
bash
who are your top three invitees and
who would bring the best gift
wow [ __ ] nine part question in
triplicate
let's break it down piece by piece go
ahead first part again
um who would you want to plan your
birthday
all right hold on i want to plan my
birthday
professor xavier because he'll know
exactly what i want
you know he'll be like to me my x-men
and he'll [ __ ] read my mind and be
like oh my god
all right kids guess what he wants um so
he'll
he'll know exactly how to get it right
what's the second part
um who are your top three invitees
well not batman he's depressing
you know he's good in a fight but not at
a [ __ ] party and [ __ ] although
you could invite bruce wayne he could
pay for it
um who's good at a party not the sandman
he's a little emo uh oh
the creeper dc's the creeper that's that
[ __ ] seems like he'd be a lot of fun
at a party man
at the very least he's like got the
outfit and [ __ ]
um tony stark
always enjoyable plus rich [ __ ] bruce
wayne uh
rich and funny so you get a life of the
party kind of guy and stuff sometimes
parties a little too much
if you remember the comics and then my
third
stanley
you know in a world where we're [ __ ]
making the fanciful happen
[ __ ] yeah that'd be amazing because the
whole time he'd be like you know you'd
[ __ ] be
just thriving on on [ __ ] tony stark
and digging what he's saying then
periodically stan would be like i
co-created him and [ __ ] like that um and
then what was the other part third part
of the question
uh who's going to bring the best gift
[Music]
hmm
i i literally stopped the show to think
about it
as if it mattered or something i was
like now hold on
um who would bring the best gift zatanna
know she's magical so at the end of the
day she can come with nothing and be
like
i'm gonna read your mind poof and i'm
like holy [ __ ] a 12 inch dick thank you
how did you know she's like you talked
about it on podcast for 10 years
what about you mark uh i had to start
writing things down so i didn't forget
them
um uh who throws my party who do i want
to plan
it um sandman he would plan the party of
my dreams
and he would also throw that [ __ ]
wherever we wanted to have it
what plane of existence would i like to
be on i'd like to be on
[ __ ] i don't know bottle city of
whatever
kandor let's do that [ __ ]
make sure you know where you're going
before you pick the place for the party
you're like the bottle city or whatever
all right
yeah bottle city of camden no we don't
want the bible city again
the most feared city
door has stolen the bottle city of
camden and superman's like go ahead
it's all yours man don't drop it
you're good um my attendees
i feel like thor is a good time at a
party
um like some ale breaks every [ __ ]
glass
you know it's all dream glass man
it's not my house wearing a chucky
cheese in my dreams that's fine
um zatanna because again you need tricks
you need a [ __ ] magician at your
party what kind of party you have
without magic tricks
absolutely nobody wants a clown that's
the joker indeed
um an iron man because again he's batman
without the angst
will bring amazing [ __ ] gifts and can
pay for it all if dream can't make that
happen if dream won't cover the check
in dream money then iron man can pick it
up
totally and also it's like he knows
people too so you know you'd be like i
don't have many people on the guest list
he's like here's mine
seriously and [ __ ] he rolls heavy
last question has i've got
some answers uh for this one
i was thinking more like i'm too old for
this but if it was like my 21st birthday
i think lobo would plan a great 21st
birthday bash
um i think the uh
invitees human torch
green lantern and lando calrissian
i feel like they'd all just be great at
a party
why lando he just seems like a party guy
colt 45 just like he seems like he knows
how to have a good time
you just want billy b williams you don't
actually want to keep lizzy
probably it had to be a fictional
character and also
i also think tony stark would bring the
best gift because
you know he said to pepper potts i'll
buy your self something nice for your
birthday
i already did so we just get to pick
whatever we wanted if tony was buying
our gift
he can't check your bank account it's
got a millionaire
um everyone how weird everybody wants
tony stark to come to their party
yeah well because he's like the one here
we've seen throw parties
actually and really it comes down to i
just want robert downey jr to come to me
which is probably like easier to get
away with than [ __ ] iron man and [ __ ]
like that like i don't know that he
would ever come to a party but he exists
in the real world i met him and [ __ ]
but everyone tells me like he'd never go
to your house i was like why
smells like weed four blocks away
i mean his house smells like alpacas so
i don't know what the difference is
no his house smells like money bro
marvel money at all his house smells
like kevin feige because it's all kevin
foggy's money
all right we've uh earned uh castle
keeper ernie o'donnell
come join us please give it up for
castle keeper ernie o'donnell ladies and
gentlemen
ernie went and got us some [ __ ]
prizes and uh very nice
very nice selection yeah i see i see
this is what yeah this is nice that's
i think that's true that's awesome
that's awesome right
right that'll and then this give me one
that's not this one but like the
plastic ones like the styrofoam ones oh
okay that's that's too difficult
two high-end too hot oh excuse me yeah
[ __ ] these people
save that for 175 dollar shows i'm sure
um okay kids uh when he goes and gets
the other thing i'll i'll
while he goes against the other thing
we'll go into this um what we have here
is uh first person that asks a
um is gonna win uh this which is the
uh uh terry fox prep um
exercise outfit from the the
you know [ __ ] world famous gymnasium
scene from yoga hosers ladies and
gentlemen
so it's a screen worn costume some young
teenager wore this in the motion picture
and it will now be yours and you could
either wear it because it's totally
wearable
or you could put it up online good luck
on ebay
i try to i tried to sell yoga hosers the
movie on ebay and it didn't work
so i don't know if you'll be able to
sell that but uh that's what we're going
to go for first for the first question
this is what you're going to win right
here
sized um
adult small so
who's got a dog who would like to wear
good luck squeezing into it ladies and
gentlemen
um all right here we go aaron pick uh
let's we can put the lights on
and uh you could uh pick or pick the
person we're going to talk to
oh i see it wait you know what this how
big is that
this size small but you know what
they're asking me to keep you on camera
so stay like yeah
like in front of the big the big burly
guy right there
[Music]
if i was you i'd be like [ __ ] you little
scrawny guy over there
there you go rick darius ladies and
gentlemen um okay
what's your name uh you go bring a mic
to him don't [ __ ] you just said he
said yeah he said stay in front of
camera [ __ ]
he's right i did say that i can't my
mark how about
do you do me a is josh is struggling to
get you turn your back to the wall there
you go
and even though you're talking to me
address it to the camera so they can
look at you but when i give you the
answer
you can look at me it won't be creepy
like this where you're looking over
there
so when i tell you just look at me look
at me
losers look at me look at the uh look at
the camera and give me your question i'm
gonna look at you on the monitor right
here go ahead
all right uh with uh moon knight and
blade coming back into the mcu what do
you think is going to happen with
werewolf by night my favorite d-lister
in the marvel universe i'm hoping the
marvel horror has become a
and uh how do you think he'll be treated
all right look at me
look at me um okay i
actually happen to have like a little
[ __ ]
inside [ __ ] dope on this man like nor
as you were asking the question i was
like what am i gonna do with that
but then i was like i could [ __ ] what
we can get on
comicbookresourcesandcomicbook.com
with a little piece of [ __ ] news that
i've never
talked about before but since i'm
answering your question
i think it's appropriate so i don't know
if many folks remember but two years ago
when we announced hey we're going to be
doing masters of the universe which is
now about to happen
we also announced hey we're going to be
doing howard the duck
over at hulu remember that yes so for a
red hot minute i was working on
howard the duck and um before dave got
involved
he was uh my co-owner and he was really
the guy that ran the thing he's from
adult swim and [ __ ]
absolute [ __ ] genius but um when it
was just uh me when jeff loeb was like
hey man uh
he called me up and he goes i think he'd
be good for howard the [ __ ] duck
that was when jeff was running marvel
television so i was like get the [ __ ]
out of here oh my god that'd be so much
fun
i reached out to walter flanagan from
comic book men
and jay and zombop superstash and i was
like hey man [ __ ]
howard the duck you're going to let me
do out of the ducks so like i'm going to
[ __ ] take a stab at like
all the [ __ ] 70s characters man like
obviously not allowed to play with
like you know big marvel the bug hit you
right that bug [ __ ]
went right to your face it's crazy these
[ __ ] leonardo bugs they're like [ __ ]
you
so um i was like i'm gonna i'm gonna
line up all the best of the 70s [ __ ]
marvel
horror comic characters who should we
get and stuff so
walt was given suggestions and of course
werewolf by night
was absolutely on the list so in my head
as i started building my
season i was like all right episode five
werewolf by night the idea of our story
was you know howard trapped here and he
was
trying to get a hold of the pages from
the dark hold
which would allow him to kind of go back
so when they did like
you know the dark hold on wanda vision i
was like holy [ __ ] man we weren't going
to do that
so there there's uh howard
you know as i'm laying it out and then i
go into
jeff and i'm like um okay so this is
what i want to do when i use this
character this character this character
and i want to use werewolf by night and
that's when
they were like um you can't use
and i can't list all the characters but
since you asked about it
they said this this and you can't use
werewolf by night
and i was like why and they were like
because
the movie division is using werewolf by
night and i was like
what the [ __ ] i was like one of the
easier who goes i don't know but kevin
please
never tell anybody that i told you
[Laughter]
so does that mean werewolf my night is
gonna pop up in [ __ ] doctor strange
multiverse of madness
likely not but it means that the movie
division was like
all of these characters you're not
allowed to touch
because we are going to be using them
as we delve deeper into marvel horror
now mind you this was like two [ __ ]
years ago and stuff
but yeah for for that reason i wasn't
allowed to
go near werewolf by night so that to me
says you know i'm not saying like
they're planning it right now
but somebody somewhere important was
like
you're not allowed to play with that
action figure we've got plans for that
one so
i hope so fingers crossed sooner or
later we'll see
all right and look what you won man give
it up for me won that
yoga hoses outfit
yeah what he said quite small so be very
careful with the
you went you saw yogurt in the vents oh
my god pin that [ __ ] to your wall man
that's going to be amazing
[ __ ] night look at that so it's gone
to an actual yoghouser's
witness [ __ ] a don't really call them
fans it's like i saw it that's what i
get a lot of
uh come on question two uh castle keeper
ernie o'donnell pick somebody oh hold on
then
look at him um how about you turn
and how are you good sir face the back
of the room where josh is oh look at
that shot and i'm in it still
soft in the back look at this [ __ ] now
yeah pull to pull to them
wait for the wait until this is very
cinematic so hold on them
and josh then i'm gonna then i'm gonna
um i'll give you a cue to pull to me
ready all right
ernie you and what's your name question
asker david
ernie and david um here just we'll do a
quick scene
you go i david you go
i love you ernie you go
but what about your husband and david
you go
[ __ ] him and then josh rack to me okay
all right here we go ready and action
i love you but what about your husband
oh [ __ ] him
see this is this kind of [ __ ] that i
need when i direct my short this is what
i really want to just [ __ ]
soak up yeah this is what you're missing
um all right
uh on to your question david what would
you like to know i can't believe i was
directed by kevin smith
let's just get out of the way now your
career is ruined
you asked justin long he'll tell you man
okay so my question is combines let's
combine
where we are right now birthplace of
clerks yes
with what's coming out next week july
23rd
master's universe oh yeah ted lasso
so let's let's take the main characters
of clerks
and rick darris and which characters
from he-man
are they most similar to oh
[ __ ] good question you know what
that's going to win you
a bratzy
now we made a bunch of these broxies to
stand in on set
so this is this was a stand in broxy man
is that the scale cap for you this is
the what is that the scale
for yeah that's my dick size right there
yeah
modeled after after me uh he's got a
little wiener he's uh
he's painted he's all yours for that
good question
now uh you can face me now yeah
in fact you can sit down you're blocking
my shot get the [ __ ] out
um let's see um okay
he-man prince adam
well wow i was gonna say all right
prince adam
dante he-man randles
elias orco
jay and silent bob
cringer and battle cat i was going to
say
i was going to say man at orange and
battle cap but yeah i guess so
although they don't seem wizard enough
to be those characters
hold on let me take it back elias not
orco
jay and silent bob orco
the two of them are cute enough to
[ __ ] and idiotic enough
and bad at magic enough to be worked out
um that would mean elias is roboto
and then
veronica would be tila
um who i'm pretty sure is in our series
um
trying to think who else
i guess i covered most of the main
characters i mean
ernie's here so rick darius
and katelyn brie you're right uh caitlin
bree the sorceress
um sadly we lost lisa um so she's
she's a spiritual being now quite like
the softwares
um hmm
[Music]
and then and then rick darris who drives
a trans
am in he-man
stratos i'd make him straddles um
yeah what about you mark or does mark
get a shot
not really like what
[Laughter]
it does not really that's a good
question and a halfway decent answer
give it up for
david he won a broxy
yeah i don't want to be responsible for
anybody getting that tiny dick
already carrying him over by the dick
ladies and gentlemen
look at that people really win at spot
castle
pam oh bamf man has joined in something
important must be happening what is that
man
i just want to point out we've probably
done close to 300 fat man beyonds and i
think that's the first
nudity that we've had on the show
first but not the last i'm gonna go dick
out at the end of the show
um okay our third uh question asker
ladies and gentlemen
is going to win this one of a kind
marvel knights philo facts
that's right ladies and gentlemen this
came straight from the 90s
from the good folks at marvel knights
joe casada
jimmy palmiotti look at it it's got a
pad in it for like back in the day when
we used to write things down
ladies and gentlemen and it's embossed
in leather or pleather whatever this may
be
it says marvel knights right there so if
you like your marvel history if you like
your daredevil and [ __ ] like that
this is the filo facts to have if you've
been like man oh man it's been 20 years
since i've seen a filofax
now now's your chance to own one um
pick pick a girl you're always picking
i am all over it i had her pre-picked
already such a sausage party
oh yes look at she knows better than you
she's like
check my ass out [ __ ] uh what's
your name my friend
tara everyone give it up to tara she's
asking questions
[Music]
all right tara it's a weird setup but
you look into that camera and you talk
to me and somehow i'll respond it's like
zoltar and big
so for both of you as filmmakers
if you had to direct and create a porno
between an avenger and a justice league
who would you choose number one that
definitely wins this
um and uh know notice we had two dudes
and asked geeky questions and then the
ladies like what about sex
um okay so it's a porno and i gotta pick
a an avenger and a leaguer
justice leaguer and [ __ ] just us
nudity um
all right
mike zapzik from comic book men
very quietly and creepily from the
audience
answer the question i don't think for
anybody but himself but he was like
black widow and zatanna
that's why i don't even think you heard
the question you're just saying [ __ ] out
loud
i always wanted to give them [ __ ]
that's why they canceled the [ __ ]
show mike
um okay um you know let's see who do i
want to see
[ __ ] because that's the thing it's like
basically there's got to be two people
you want to see
[ __ ] and you want to see something like
[ __ ] spectacular
[ __ ] like not just like you know [ __ ]
two girls you can see that on [ __ ]
you know
youtube and [ __ ] not youtube but [ __ ]
pornhub
um you want something like [ __ ] up man
like you want
like the thing was an avenger once
wasn't he
ben grimm
i want to see that big rock and [ __ ]
[ __ ] of his
so you got ben grimm the thing
and who's he [ __ ] is he gotta be
justice leaguer
all right so i did my marvel quota and
so for dc
who's gonna take that
oh all right i [ __ ] you know what
it's going to be colorful
and it's going to be it's going to be
it's going to be hot but it's heads up
it's going to be a little gay as well
we got the thing we got martian
manhunter
orange and green man and he gets to
change
shapes and [ __ ] like that so we get a
bunch of people
with jon jones right he could look like
martian manhunter he could look like
[ __ ] black widow and zatanna so mike
can jerk off and be happy
um he could look like like a few
ex-girlfriends of mine just to mix it up
and [ __ ] like that
and then finish hard in his natural form
or something you know when he comes he's
like oh
and he speaks like a wrong mirror and
[ __ ] like that
um that's that's what i'm picking what
about you mark
uh you know at first i went very [ __ ]
vocabulary
there was a robe flutter i could tell
there was some business happening
um at first i went vanilla at first i
was like well [ __ ] thor and wonder
woman that makes sense right cool i'd
watch that
boring and then i was like we're calling
this movie
it ain't easy coming green and it's the
incredible hulk
and green lantern
[Music]
that is good because you're going to get
all sorts of hulk [ __ ] close-up action
yeah and toys like you wouldn't believe
it's just
wish fulfillment with green lantern's
like what do you wanna [ __ ]
or what do you wanna [ __ ] you admit
there's a giant locomotive coming right
for the hulk's anus
that's true man the hulk would be like
hulk smash damn
[ __ ] hulk get railed run a train on
hulk
well hope to die
so very hot man uh that definitely
deserves this give it up for ladies and
gentlemen
pam
my uh my favorite one in chat comes from
the twitch
channel uh which is rakso228 said
swamp thing and clayface
that's the message those are both those
are both dc
wait a minute he bent the rules never
mind
um poison ivy and swamp thing would be
kind of cool
like plant on plant [ __ ] or a man thing
right great vegan i'm sorry [ __ ] all you
people but
as a vegan they got me very excited in
fact i'm gonna text my daughter about it
right now
yes so many leaves um that's
all the questions we got so when we do
the news and then we do the questions
that's that's basically all the show we
got you got anything left mark
uh the tank is empty my friend it really
really is and that's always a good sign
um we of course will be back next week
mark won't be here
although he won't be here for a [ __ ]
wonderful reason always spend time
with mom kids uh griffin newman orco
from uh from masters of the universe and
of course
arthur from from the tick on amazon will
be joining us for fat man beyond tickets
are on sale right now
at smodcastle.com uh the jeff's kiss
t-shirt ladies and gentlemen
uh it's on sale right now if i was smart
i had i would have brought a bunch here
to the theater but i'm
not smart ladies and gentlemen i i
remember there was a big box and i took
a shirt for myself and i felt so clever
at that moment
it wasn't until i was here going like
everyone should buy one and i was like i
could have sold them
um so they're available at jsonbob.com
you can pick them up there mark you sell
things uh where would you like to send
people to sell things i do occasionally
sell things um one
can go to uh amazon.com
and or comixology.com to get a hold of
my new graphic novel adora in the
distance
which is currently available for
download and sale and if you're an
amazon prime member you get to read it
for free don't cost you anything extra
um or embattledclothing.com which is
where i have my fancy t-shirts
um they are not jeff's kiss worthy but
they're pretty good
i'll take them yeah don't [ __ ]
compete with our t-shirt this week man
[Music]
in case folks uh i haven't seen we
talked about last week there was a
thr piece and i saw another piece this
week as well congratulations mike
thank you and we are now officially
nominated for a harvey award
yeah for a digital
digital book of the year um so i feel
pretty good about that
very very very cool man congratulations
way to [ __ ] bury the lead and hold
that to the end and [ __ ]
was wrong there there was a little bit
left in the tank yeah
apparently just a little bit um just
when you thought mark had put it all the
way in he's like six more inches um
hopefully you folks at home have had a
good time hopefully folks here at smog
castle do you enjoy yourself this
[Applause]
evening
cannot thank you enough uh for coming
out man this is a dream come true the
smod castle uh
thing of ours that we're doing here and
uh doing fat man beyond here twice so
far has been
absolutely wonderful we'll continue this
all throughout the summer
as well we'll keep doing the show on the
weekends and stuff i'm busy during the
week
uh but during the weekends we'll be able
to to do the show uh on monday don't
forget big announcement about the ship
that we're working on
um and uh and so look for that we'll be
talking about that next week
uh on the show um but uh
please uh give it up for uh the
the guy who makes sure that everyone at
home gets to watch not just people here
in the theater and then
chimes in from time to time with
interesting factoids
banff man himself jason
uh give it up for the man who [ __ ]
went and got the prizes real quick and
then pick the questioners and [ __ ] like
that
and then make sure that everyone's
comfortable and that the [ __ ]
toilet's working so that everybody can
take a [ __ ]
make sure that make sure everyone's
comfy and [ __ ] make sure everyone gets
in here from quick stop the beautiful
thing about spot castle is people buy
drinks and snacks
over a quick stop and [ __ ] and it's
ernie's job to make sure like everybody
get in the theater it's time to do the
show and [ __ ]
uh give it up for castle keeper ernie
o'donnell
uh we got uh wayne on the door he's the
one who got you in here give it up for
wayne ladies and gentlemen
uh you got you saw him before the human
mic stand but he does so much more for
us man he's back there making sure that
everyone can hear us and why not give it
up for christian ladies and gentlemen
way back there the man who's making sure
you can see me
and you can see the show and you can see
the people at the theater pull out and
everybody in the
audience turn and wave to good old josh
roush ladies and gentlemen
uh but as we all know that [ __ ] bug
is back
man just landed a [ __ ] what a showbiz
[ __ ]
what a spotlight hog it's the ben
affleck of bugs ladies and gentlemen
um uh give it up for the man without
whom there is no uh fat man beyond the
only good writer on this show ladies and
gentlemen the man in the box big brother
behind me mark
bernardin
[Music]
and that ladies and gentlemen is fat man
beyond for this week i'm kevin smith
and i am mark bernard tune in next time
same
fat time same fat channel spodcast.com
or
youtube.com kevin smith jeff's kiss
everybody good night
you